did you grow up obsessing over the  disney princess's beauty looks  we hear you but we know each of these  ladies can up her style game  after all most of them have been around  for decades so they're well overdue a  makeover  they deserve to get their brows on fleek  and their hair on point  because they're worth it right and  artist dudel miss san emiterio agrees  with us  she's brought their makeup bang up to  date with subtle glow-ups  join us as we check out her top tik-tok  [Music]  transformations  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  which disney princess glow up is your  favorite we need to know what you think  so be sure to sound off in the comments  section and please hit subscribe while  you're here  thanks for watching you beauties